ti sei messo nella tua fatto del tuo
habitat questa band di ragazzi lui
questo punto se lo fa perché ci siamo
con sasha non tradì spero che non sia
come la prossima come l'altra volta
perché no che pesce lancia allora siamo
sui draw per 6 robert vi servirebbe che
tu te stassi questa cosa andando per
primo piangiamo sul tropper scherzo
finito malissimo
allora bisogna arrivare in fondo
semplicemente buttandosi io non ho mai
fatto questa cosa è effettivo di resta
con l'aia progetto neanche sono nostra
mi sa che questa parte solo per farti
capire come funziona ok alla fra esploso
male per fare nuovi inviti bisogna fare
qua aiuto e rilevare start game e
abbiamo fatto a questo testo tu vai non
è semplicemente una parte non sono morto
ma è infatti non importano importa
tranquillo gli va avanti ma non so
perché non sei morto non vide ecco ma
cosa vuol dire aveva anticipato
sbagliati rigore che sono quello che fa
il bagno esatto tu paghi la devi
prendere le cose che amico fabi ci sono
già preso facendo esattamente ci siamo
let's go allora qua siam al 2 il 2
demi schivare le automobili penso sia
una cosa abbastanza fattibile
by perfetto c'è solo dolore nuovo
impegno imposto invece ha detto o fatto
59 ci hanno fatto per niente
eri sempre partendo la tassa insicuri o
prova magari anche si riesce
no amico mio oscar ho capito come si fa
c'è un modo molto più easy molto molto
molto più intensi si fida ti aspetta che
vengo aspetta sofferta spiega manna cam
anna guardami dove vado
allora tutto a destra bypassi tutto e
poi alla fine
ti muovi è per niente non c'ero entrato
voglio sentire lorenzo che dice ce l'ho
fatta vorrei poter telo dire ma fai
sentire proprio lorenzoni ce l'ho fatta
ok giro presso voglio proprio sentire
più la siamo fatta ce l'ha fatta
si fa vedere quello dopo intanto giusto
per farvi un'idea ma questo di venire a
vederlo aiuto spiega non ti saprei
spiegare che cos'è
credimi non saprei cosa dirti madonna ok
viola non è vero sono molto sull'ultima
trave l'ultima ero sopra il coso ma dai
bravo poi però un passo con loro ce l'ho
fatta ce l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta ha
visitato dal tuo punto non ti ho seguito
ho fatto quello che ho fatto tu io sono
scopatore di bug si o no vieni vieni ti
aspetto guardavi si è schiantato
fortissimo poi tra l'altro è tutto
arcobaleno giusto livello mi piace
vediamo abbiamo qua perfetto tanto vedo
come quello dopo ti faccio sapere
e vai vai giusto per capire la pace il
check points le miss i quattro vediamo
madonna può voglio morire dentro non
vedo neanche dove il punto dove deve
arrivare qua sasha ho fatto quello che
fa non ci credo
a cosa mancava a caso baccano a questo
veramente ti giuro a caso non tentativo
di prova con futuro dopo il caso dai
eccolo
grazie del pomodoro sono stati bravi
fino adesso e sono stati bravi gh5 manca
il 5 ma ce la facciamo la facciamo li
trascina lo scopriamo insieme tra 28 c è
qualcun altro ha uguale c'è un pupazzo
di neve o mio dio al primo tentativo
sasha il primo tentativo ti voglio
fidati secondo me lo fai al primo
tentativo in quando ma cosa vuol dire ma
no non è possibile
e invece ti dimostro che lo è vado
sono morto sascha abbiamo preso il nulla
e anche io ho preso nulla avrebbero non
c'era nulla
addio centro al 100 al centro buttati al
centro fidati al centro al centro
vedibili quasi al traguardo mi hai fatto
davvero non è possibile che grande no
altri che tu vai dall'altra parte
dall'altra parte ma era gay
d'altra parte tutto nome tutto dritto sì
grazie saggia prego me e riverite cose
vecchie lo so sono lo scavatore di
segreto disterebbe questa roba c'è
un'altra moneta professore file intenso
colleziona minima mano veramente un tubo
potrei aver trovato il bug supremo tu
non ci credi fino ad ora diventi
miliardario sono uscito va bene non vedo
neanche mi butto mi fido di me stesso
social ci credo ce l'ha fatta ma come lo
giuro ho te lo giuro subito già fatte al
primo subito non è mai il tuo culo è
grosso incredibile ma non so cosa dirti
te lo giuro pazzesco parte c'è un
labirinto bettola la moneta come avevate
evelyn non era difficile bravo bravo
lasciato la morte magari centrato il
punto che pirla che prima keep it che
marchetti ma guarda bar è che se mi
impegno possa essere così stupido ad ora
e stato richiamo al settimo dobbiamo
fare settimo eccolo concentrato o bio
bio scariche elettriche
proprio no è tranquillo non si vede
neanche dove ci dobbiamo buttare in
mezzo qua si no vabbè un casino ma
rispetto agli altri questo non è
complica certo dico io che sembra lo
studio qua è per niente se non sono
morto l'ho pagato l'ho pagata l'ho
pagato lo vagato vero prove cavoli suoi
jensen ho toccato un punto e poi ho
camminato praticamente fatto si vanta ea
[Musica]
bebè tipo una serata di gabry ponte alla
gara si momenti cosa da fare secondo
vinto non è vero preso la moneta per
farla fare questi momenti non era una
sua etica e inimitabile col piange cosa
devi fare
non piangete entry qua no prezzo o ce
l'ho fatta io ti segue lo faccio non
capisco come quello che copia i compiti
e prende di più ho capito a banca 2 paga
finita per loro questo livello
dell'inter
no ma questa difficilissima questa è
veramente difficile non capisci dove
sono i buchi permette un casino ai
provocarti in mezzo tipo questo momento
io non c'entro neanche il primo cioè so
dove il bouquet loro centro thais http
ngo il punto che ho scoperto a 13 questo
è il primo che ha scoperto il bug va il
primo che ha scoperto il bug uno bravo
estromette se la difficoltà è dunque 34
c non è vero non è vero toccato il
bordino magagna ce l'ho fatta sasha ce
l'ho fatto lo farà
sì sì ti prego
fammi chiudere starò bravissimo voglio
andare a casa madonna è stato orribile
orribile orribile non voglio più vedere
niente di questo genere mai la vita non
più di tutto vai più disparati cavatore
verso trombe parlerò il nove come un
incubo 10 award sace buio ma come si
vabbè vabbè dai euro è un rapper al buio
vuol dire che vuol dire che non vedi gli
ostacoli muori a caso non vedi niente
vedi solo nome di niente
scusami non vedi dove ti stai buttando
non vedi nulla dove il traguardo
ecco qua saresti utile tool a buttarci
pomodori per vedere cose che impatta ma
dai ma ce lo è
no io non c'ero per niente come non vedo
niente non vedo niente allora non vedi
ma non vedo cosa buttata cosa mi
ammazzano lo vedo cv bhutto e prego di
non morire perché non solo adesso cosa
sto impattando qua cosa mia cosa stai ma
dai ma dai fatta cioè fatta
povero
sono contento io lo faccio finire
procedere tornava indietro va indietro
quando sei in cima a cercare per la
paracadute di entrare un coso
ok perfetto e devi cercare di prendere
il primo di quelli di che vedi in basso
basso con l'art no no no no quelle
lustro lino in basso si prenda rincon
seduta ti prendi lo è perché penso che
scendi giù un normale frank e fai il
normale come sempre uno che prende il
coso blu sale fino ai 49 fatto il 10
euro il lavoro di squadra va bene ma
perché questa cosa qua era per passare a
perché quella finale
alla fine la prima a cavo non lo sapevo
mio dio orribile orribile paga corribile
grazie mille sei stato super sasha stato
bravissimo a pagare il gioco mamma mia
voglio mai di toccare l'oggetto quindi
spero che vi sia piaciuto ringrazio
sasha questo canale anche descrizione è
io come sempre conclude video spero che
vi si chiuda certo punto le piace quali
si cerca di iniziare senza visti
schietti e ci vediamo al prossimo video
dai ragazzi
[Musica]